[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم توصلت ايران ومجموعه 5د واح مساء
الخميس في سويسرا الى اتفاق اطاري بشان
برنامج طهران النووي ينتظر ان يمهد الى
اتفاق النهائي بشان الملف نهايه يونيو
المقبل نتوقف مع هذا الخبر نناقشه في
محورين ما هي المكاسب التي حققها طرفا
الاتفاق وما حجم التنازلات التي قدمها من
اجل التوصل الى
ابرامه وما مدى امكانيه استكمال الاتفاق
في ضوء الحسابات الداخليه والاقليميه
والدوليه المرتبطه
[موسيقى]
به بعد 12 عاما من الشد والجذب بشان ملف
ايران النووي توصلت طهران ومجموعه 5 ئد
واح الىى اتفاق اطاري وضع الاسس حسب
موقعيه لاتفاق نهائي حوله نهايه شهر يونيو
حزيران المقبل ردود الفعل الغربيه رحبت في
معظمها بما تحقق من دون ان يمنع هذا وجود
تحفظات عليه في الولايات المتحده واسرائيل
اما في ايران التي رات في الاتفاق ضمانا
لحقها في مواصله تخصيب اليورانيوم فقد
واجه المحافظون ما تم بانتقال
بلغت حد وصف الاتفاق بان ايران قايضت
بتوقيعه حصانها المسرج بحصان ذي لجام
مكسور مثل ما قال شريعه مدار مستشار
المرشد الايراني علي خامنائي
[تصفيق]
كالفاتحه احتفالات اخرى في بلاد الفت شعار
الموت للشيطان الاكبر منذ
عقود وثم ايضا ما يعتبره رون اشواقا
مكبوته لعلاقات مختلفه مع الغرب واخرى
هاجسها الانصراف الى الداخل ومشاغله بعد
سنوات من الاشتباك والعداء مع الخارج انجز
اتفاق الاطار اذا بما يمنح طرفيه حق ادعاء
النصر لكن التفاصيل تظل حاسمه قبل ان يصبح
الاتفاق نهائيا بنهايه يونيو حزيران
المقبل يقضي اتفاق الاطار بان توقف ايران
تشغيل اكثر من ثلثي اجهزتها للطرد المركزي
وبتفك مفاعل قد ينتج البلوتونيوم وبقبول
اجراءات شامله للتحقق من التنفيذ في مقابل
رفع تدريجي للعقوبات عنها على ان تلك تظل
عناوين عامه تكتنز بالتفاصيل التي لم تحسم
بعد وفي حال حسمها فان المنطقه لا ايران
وحسب تكون قد دخلت مرحله جديده يؤرخ لها
وبها كالصاعقه نزل الاعلان على اسرائيل
حاولت منعه بكل طريقه ممكنه ووصل الامر
بنتنياهو الى الاشتباك مع اوباما لكن
خيارات تل ابيب كما يرجح كثيرون تظل
محدوده فالضرب العسكريه احتمال بعيد ما
يفسر خفض نتنياهو لسقف مطالبه بضروره
تضمين الاتفاق النووي النهائي اعتراف
طهران بحق اسرائيل في الوجود واذا كان هذا
شان اسرائيل فان وضع الجوار العربي يبدو
اكثر تعقيدا وتشوش وتتراوح خيارات بعض
دوله بين الدخول في سباق نووي غير محمود
العواقب او الاعتراف بالامر الواقع وهو ان
ايران في سبيلها لانهاء عزلتها مع ما
يعنيه ذلك من نفوذ قد يتزايد بفعل الافراج
عن ارصدتها المجمده وعودتها الى سوق النفط
من اوسع ابوابه ايران في راي من يخشاها هي
من يتحكم بمفاتيح الصراع في سوريا والعراق
ولبنان واليمن قبل الاتفاق فما بالك بعده
لكنها في راي اخرين قد تكون هي نفسها من
يتخلى عن ذلك لانه ادى الغرض منه وهو
تحسين اعاده تموضعها في المنطقه عبر اتفاق
دولي وما دام ذلك قد حدث فانها قد تتخلى
في رايهم عن الاسد بل وتعيد بناء علاقتها
مع حزب الله على اسس جديده وثم ما يزيد
بان الداخل الايراني قد يصبح هو الاولويه
على حساب فائض الانشغال بالخارج وذلك وحده
كفيل بتفكيك النزعات الامبراطوريه في
ايران اي انتصار خاتمي ومسوي على خامنئي
واحمد نجاد اما الخاسر الاكبر في هذه
الحاله فهو مؤسسه الولي الفقيه قبل
سواها موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيوفنا من
واشنطن السفير جيمس جيفري نائب مستشار
الامن القومي الامريكي سابقا والمسؤول
السابق عن ملف ايران في الخارجيه
الامريكيه من طهران ما شاء الله شمس
الواعظين مستشار مركز الشرق الاوسط
للدراسات الاستراتيج
ومن الكويت الدكتور عبد الله الشايجي
استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه الكويت
اهلا بضيوفي الكرام وابدا بضيفي من طهران
سيد ما شاء الله شمس الواعظين لما تبدو
الاشارات الوارده من طهران ليست على قلب
واحد بينما يصف الانجاز بانه انتصار وخطوه
مهمه لرفع العقوبات وبين فريق اخر يصفه
بانه اتفاق غير متوازن
اطلاقا اعتق اقد ان المحافظين في كل مكان
يعني ان كانت في واشنطن او او طهران
ياخذون نفس الموقف لكن كل
على حسابه و عقيدته فيما يتعلق او قراءته
ل لهذا الملف او هذا الاتفاق لكن المهم
كنت اتي الى استديو الشوارع طهران في هذه
اللحظات تمتلئ ب بال الناس و الشارع
الايراني نزل الى الشارع ليحتفل
بهذا الاتفاق في هذه اللحظات هذا يعني ان
الشعب الايراني كله يقف الى جانب هذا
الاتفاق و يقف الى جنب قيادته يحتفل بماذا
سي ماشء الله يحتفل
بماذا يحتفل بالاتفاق يعتبر ان هذا
الاتفاق كان متوازنا وكان لصالح ايران
يعني اسمح لي ان اشير الى ثلاث نقاط مهمه
ايران كانت تريد انتزاع اي اعتراف دولي
بحقها ب عمليه ترصيب او امتلاك دوره نوويه
مسالمه هذا ما حصلت عليه ايران كانت تريد
ان يعترف العالم بان كل العقوبات المفروضه
ان كانت في اطار مجلس الامن او احاديه
الجانب من قبل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
او الاتحاد الاوروبي عقوبات ظالمه ويجب
رفعها وهذا ما سيحصل بعد ابرام الاتفاق او
تفاصيل الاتفاق والنقطه الثالثه تطوير
برنامج السلمي في في المستقبل هذا ما حصلت
عليه ايران وبتعاون دولي ماذا كانت تريد
طهران هذه النقاط الثلاث وقد حصلت عليه
اعتقد ان ايران ستستمر بالتعاون مع
المنظومه الدوليه ودول خمسه زائد واحد وفي
المستقبل
ستستطيع مع مع مساعده هذه الدول من
تطوير بعض ما ما يسمى
هنا التنازلات الايرانيه فيما يتعلق ب ماء
الثقيل في يعني منشاه اراك او منشاه فودر
عن عن حقيقه ما تم التواصل اليه وان سؤالي
موجه للسيد جيمس جيفري ضيفي من
واشنطن ما تفسير ان كلا الطرفين سيد جفري
وصف هذا الاتفاق بالانتصار وتحقيق الخطوه
التاريخيه ما الذي حدث حتى يوصف من قبل
الطرفين بانه
انتصار اولا الايرانيون حصلوا على كل ما
يريدون كل منشات ستبقى
مفتوحه ولن يقروا او يعترفوا او يجعل
عليهم فرض بان يعترفوا بانهم ما زال لديهم
بعدا عسكريا في بحثهم النووي في مقابل ذلك
يحصلون على رفع للعقوبات الولايات المتحده
والدول الاخرى الاعضاء في الخمسه زائد
واحد من ناحيه اخرى ايضا هم بدورهم
اكتسبوا الكثير من الوقت
لان قدر تخصيب اليورانيوم الذي ستكون
ايران قادر على انتاجه سيكون
مقيدا بشكل
صارم واستخدام هذا ال اليورانيوم المخصب
سيكون تحت سيطره وضبط اذا هذا يجعل من
الصعوبه على ايران ان تطور سلاحا نوويا في
اقل من
عام دكتور عبد الله عندما نتكلم عن اتفاق
بين الطرفين كما ذكرت قبل قليل يوصف ب
الانتصار من قبل الفريقين باعتقادك ماذا
عن جانب التنازل من الطرفين فيما يتعلق
بما تم عليه الاتفاق في هذا الاتفاق
الاطاري حتى
الان شكرا تحياتي لك و الضيوف
والمشاهدين طبعا يعني يعني هناك واضح في
براغماتيه من ايران هناك واضح بان في
ثلاثه انجازات في اعتقادي وفي تنازلات من
الطرفين وكذلك في يعني ما نسميه العصا
والجزره والحوافز التي قدمت ان هذه الف
اتفاقيه التي كانت حتى قبل يومين مستبعده
بسبب المواقف المتباينه من الطرفين تثبت
ثلاث اشياء بالنسبه الى ايران والى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والمجموعه 5
زد واح الاول هو ان النووي الايراني هو
كان ولا يزال غايه وليس هدفا لتعضيد
ولزياده قوه وتاثير ووزن ايران في الساحه
الاقليميه والدوليه ليحت وزير خارجيه
الدوله مثل ايران مع الخمسه الكبار زائد
المانيا هذا بحد ذاته بالنسبه للايرانيين
يعد انجاز كبير النقطه الثانيه العقوبات
كانت هي السبب التي دفعت ايران لان تاتي
وما سماها المرشد وهو محق بذلك التنازلات
البطوليه التي من خلالها تعمل ايران
والمرشد مطلع على كل خطوه وكل بند من
الاتفاق الاطار النقطه الثالثه وهي النقطه
المهمه وهي تثبت بان هناك الان في في في
صراع واضح بين البراجماتيين المعتدلين
الذي يقودهم روحاني ظريف وبين الان الذي
سنبدا نسم مع الكثير من الانتقادات التي
سيعبر عنها يعني الان الجناح المحافظ والى
الان لم نسمع المرشد وما هو موقفه ولكن
قاعد نسمع من شريعه مداري واخرين بالحرس
الثوري يمكن يبداوا يوزعون الادوار بان
هذا الاتفاق قد لا يكون ما نريده وطبعا
يعني بنهايه الامر اي اتفاق يتم التوصل
اليه هو عباره عن تنازلات من كلا الطرفين
النقطه المهمه في كل هذا نعم في كان
تنازلات ان ايران حافظت نعم على منشاتها
النوويه ولكن كلا الطرفين يقدم صوره
مختلفه عن الاخر يعني كاننا نحن امام
مشهدين مختلفين الطرف الامريكي يقول ايران
تنازلت ايران اعطت الكثير ايران وافقت على
ان تخفض نسبه التقصيب الى
3.67% لمده 15 عاما سنه كامله ما في تقصيب
لنتاكد من ايران العقوبات لن ترفع كما
يقول اليوم روحاني لخطابه للشعب الايراني
وكذلك ظريف لن ترفع مباشره بل تدريجيا
وبعد ان يتم التاكد من قبل الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه بالتزام ايران يعني
ايران قاعد تسوق للداخل الايراني الذي
انهك من العقوبات بان هذا انتصار وهو الى
حد ما صحيح ولكن ليس بالصوره التي قاعد
تصور ان ايران تقدمت تنازلات ايران يعني
وافقت على اكثر نظام صرامه في الرقابه من
قبل الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه على كل
منشاتها منشاه فوردو س تتحول الى منشاه
علميه وليس ب وليس نوويه وكذلك يعني تنازل
عن البلوتونيوم منشاه اراق التي تنتج
البلوتونيوم الماده الرئيسيه لانتاج
القنبله النوويه سيتم تعطيلها كليا وهذا
يعني ان كما يقول اوباما امس بان ايران
قطعت طريق امامها من كل السبل لان تصبح
دوله تنتج سلاح نووي وهذا بالنسبه
للامريكيين ووباء كبير يخلده ضمن الرؤساء
العظام بالنسبه للامريكان يروجون ان هذا
انتصار ويوم تاريخي بالنسبه للايراني
يروجون انتصار ويوم تاريخي لانه حقق
لايران المكانه دوله عندها قدره على
التخصيب وحقا في التخصيب لم تغلق اي منشاه
خفضت البلوتونيوم وخفضت اليورانيوم
وتنازلت عن عن السلاح النووي ورفعت عنها
العقوبات بشكل متدرج وهذا يعطيها وضع
وحضور استراتيجي كبير في المنطقه وهذا ما
قد يمكن السؤال القادم اعلق عليه وهو ما
هو ردود الفعل عندنا في منطقه الخليج هذا
ما س نناقشه بعد الفاصل دكتور عبد الله
فيما يتعلق بتاثير هذا الاتفاق امكانيه
استكمال التوافق بشان ملف ايران النووي في
ضوء حسابات الاطراف المعنيه به ابقوا
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش ابعاد وتاثيرات الاتفاق النووي بين
ايران والغرب واجد تحيه لضيوفي من الكويت
وكذلك من طهران ومن واشنطن ضيفي من طهران
ما شاء الله شمس ال وعظم هل يعتقد بوجود
ملاحق تتبع هذا الاتفاق غير مصرح بها غير
معلن عنها هي التي تجعل دول المنطقه بشكل
او باخر تنظر بعين الريبه الى هذا
الاتفاق كل الجماعات او جماعات الضغط انا
اقصد اما في العاصمه طهران او في في
واشنطن تقول ان هناك بعض الملحقات جواد
الدكتور جواد زريف كان واضحا في هذا في في
هذا المجال
وايضا الرئيس الامريكي بارك اوباما لا
توجد اي ملاحق في فيما يتعلق
ب هذا هذا الاتفاق ولكن ستوجد
هناك هذا الملف عريض وطويل كما يقال لذلك
اعتقد الى نهايه حزيران يونيو القادم
ستكون هناك هنا مفاوضات مكثفه لاخذ
التفاصيل
و وتبديلها الى نصوص فنيه من ناحيه ومن
ناحيه اخرى النص السياسي الذي سينهي هذا
هذا الاتفاق ب الذي يسمى اتفاق اطار
الاتفاق الحالي فيما يتعلق بنقطه مهمه جدا
اعتقد ان طالما ايران كانت تؤكد
ان لا نيه لها لامتلاك اي سلاح نووي لذلك
اعتقد ان ما يقال
حول عدم قدره ايران لصناعه قنبله
النوويه في المستقبل اعتقد ان هذا هو
تحصيل حاصل بالنسبه لايران لان الفتوى
للمرشد الجمهوريه ايه الله علي خامنائي
كانت قبل هذه المفاوضات وقبل هذا هذا
الاتفاق بتحريم اي صناعه القنبله او
استخدام
القنبله النوويه لذلك لم يستطع الغرب او
بعض الدول او بعض الجهات تقول باننا
انتزعنا
هذا ه هذا الميل الايراني او الرغبه
الايرانيه لامتلاك السلاح النووي كلما في
الامر ان ايران اخذت اي تصعد بالموقف فيما
يتعلق بترسيب اليورانيوم الى درجه 20 او
اكثر بنسبه 20% لكي يقبل الغرب وهذه هندسه
السياسه لكي تتمكن ان تتفاوض مع دول 5م
زائد واحد من موقع القوه وهذا ما حصلت
عليه الايرانيون اذكياء في هذا الم في هذا
المجال
ياخذون صناعتهم او موقفهم و ويصعدون في
الموقف لكي ينتزعوا اقل الاشياء او ما ما
كانوا ينوون التو المسه ان كانت مجرد
استراتيجيه ام هي نوايا حقيقيه من قبل
ايران لامتلاك السلاح النووي السفير جيمس
جفري عندما يطلب الرئيس الامريكي بلقاء
رؤساء دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي الا يمثل
هذا هواجس حقيقيه لدى دول هذه المنطقه بان
التفاوض واي اتفاق سيكون على
حسابهم بالضبط له غرضان الغرض الاول هو
التاكيد على ان الرئيس
اوباما ينظر الى هذه الاتفاقيه بانها سوف
تكون تحل هذه القضايا وال الان هذه
الاتفاقيه وهذه النشاطات وضعت تحت عمليه
رقابه وضبط ولكن هذا لا يتم بين البلدين
على حساب الدول في المنطقه سواء كانت دول
الخليج او اسرائيل او تركيا ثانيا هو
يلتقيهم لكي يقول لهم ما الذي سيفعله وهذا
مهم اذا ما قامت ايران بعدم الامتثال مع
احكام هذه الاتفاقيه هذا هو السؤال المهم
والقضيه الاساسيه اذا ما التزمت ايران
بهذه الاتفاقيه فلن تمتلك القدره على
تطوير سلاح النووي في فتره قصيره واذا ما
انتهكوا هذه الاتفاقيه كما حدث في السابق
واذا لم تكن الولايات المتحده قادره على
التحرك فستكون هناك اجراءات اخرى دكتور
عبد الله ما مبرر مخاوف مخاوف دول المنطقه
من هذا الاتفاق سواء في شكله الاطاري او
متوقع في شكله النهائي مع الضمانات
الامريكيه بان ما تم هو انجاز تاريخي لحتى
لا تكون المنطقه او حتى لا تحصل ايران على
سلاح نووي وضمان والتزام امريكي متواصل
بامن المنطقه ما مبرر هذه
المخاوف طبعا اردني خليني اوضح في البدايه
نقطه مهمه نحن كلنا نرحب باتفاق يعني يؤدي
الى الاستقرار هذه المنطقه لان شبعنا من
حروب ومواجهات وعسكره وعدم ثقه بين
الطرفين وحرب بارده الان تدور بشكل واضح
بين الطرف الخليجي بقياده المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وبين ايران ونرى ابعادها في
العراق وسوريا ولبنان واليمن وهذا ليس خفي
على احد والامريكان يعلمون ذلك علم اليقين
ولكن منذ البدايه كان قلقنا بان امريكا لا
تاخذ بعين الاعتبار القلق والمواقف
الخليجيه التي نقلت الى واشنطن اكثر من
مره ومن اكثر من طرف بانه يجب ان يكون
ايضا جزء من النقاش هو حول كيفيه التعامل
مع التدخل والمشروع الايراني وحلفاء ايران
الذين تستقوي بهم للتاثير ومحاصر والضغط
على الاطراف حلفاء واشنطن ولهذا السبب
وصلنا الى مرحله بان حلفاء الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه يشعرون بالقلق وخصوم
حلفائها يشعرون بالارتياح كما هو الحال
الان مع مع مع الطرف الايراني فلهذا السبب
الان الرئيس اوباما طلب الان او قدم امس
بخطابه دعوه للدول الخليجيه ل قادت دول
مجلس التعاون الخليجي للمجيء الى كم ديفيد
وكم ديفيد مهم وليس واشنطن وهو يعني عباره
عن منتجع يكون فيه ال يعني ما في رسميات
بشكل كبير بل يكون فيه كلام صريح وواضح
ليطمن دول الخليج على ان هذا الاتفاق بشكل
النهائي نحن ما يهمنا الان اتفاق الاطار
هو اتفاق الاطار غير ملزم ما لم يوقع في
في نهايه جون وقد يمدد ذلك ولكن اللي
يهمنا الاتفاق النهائي بماذا سيتضمن وكيف
سيتعامل مع الامور التي تشعر دول الخليج
بانها تقلقها مما تقوم به ايران عبر
حلفائها وخاصه ان امريكا الان تعيد النظر
بقدره ايران على التحكم في المناطق نفوذها
في العراق لم تستطع ان ت يعني تسيطر على
تكريت في اليمن عاصفه الحزم خربطه الاوراق
في سوريا سقوط ادلب وبصره الشام اد
الك سوريا والم
اسي قدر دول اليج على التعا نعم كيف لدول
المنطقه ان تطمئن للسلوك الايراني حتى مع
دعوه الرئيس روحاني دول المنطقه
والاطمئنان الى حوار جدي كيف لها ان تطمئن
وايران تفعل غير ذلك بشكل عملي في العراق
في سوريا وفي اليمن وفي اماكن اخرى
انا اشاطر زميلي العزيز في في في الكويت
في هذا المجال انا اعتقد يجب على القياده
الايرانيه وتحديدا حكومه الرئيس روحاني في
هذه المرحله يعني مرحله ما بعد توفيق
توقيع الاتفاق ان تنشط في السياسه
الخارجيه فيما يتعلق بالعلاقات الخاصه مع
العربيه السعوديه ومع دول ايه الخليج لكي
لتبديد ايه مخاوف ممكن ان اي تاخذ هذه
الدول الى مسارات اخرى فيما يتعلق ب
موقفها حيال هذا هذا الاتفاق واعتقد ان
حكومه الدكتور روحاني تتجه في هذا في هذا
المجال لكن الاحداث في في اليمن ممكن ان
تعيق محاولات ايران في هذه المرحله لكن في
المرحله المقبله اعتقد ان ايران ستنشط في
هذا
المجال لانها تدرك تماما ان ان اي اتفاق
اذا اذا لم ياتي باتفاق شامل مع كل الدول
في المنطقه وفي الاقليم لتتمكن ايران من
من ضمانه الاستقرار والامن الاقليمي هذا
يعني ان اي اتفاق سيتعرض الى اهتزازات في
المستقبل ان كانت هذه الاهتزازات من قبل
دول الاقليم او من قبل دول سؤال سؤال
اخيران الوقت يداهمنا للسفير جيمس جيفري
هل في ظل طبعا في ظل المعطيات معطيات هذا
الملف معطيات المنطقه معطيات ايران وكذلك
ما يجري في المنطقه من تحولات خطيره ومهمه
سواء الوضع في العراق او في سوريا او حتى
في اليمن وفي ظل الحديث على ان هذا
الاتفاق مربوط بحسن النوايا ويساور الكثير
من الشكوك هل تعتقد بان يتم التوصل الى
اتفاق في شهر يونيو القادم سيد
جفري نعم اعتقد انه امر مرجح بانهم سوف
يتوصلوا الى اتفاقيه النهائيه بنهايه
يونيو حزيران ذلك لان كل الاطر الاساسيه
قد وضعت وتمت بحلول يوم امس اذا من الممكن
جدا للطرفين القيام بذلك فنيا وسياسيا ولا
يمكن لهم ان يبتعدوا عن الاتفاق بعد كل
هذه
الاحتفالات وبعد كل هذه التغطيات العلنيه
اذا فهذه الاتفاق
اعتقد انها سيتم العمل على انهائها
واختتامها بشهر يونيو اشكرك كت معنا من
واشنطن السفير جيمس جيفري نائب مستشار
الامن القومي الامريكي سابقا والمسؤول
السابق عن ملف ايران في الخارجيه
الامريكيه شكرا جزيل لك كما اشكر ضيفي من
طهران ما شاء الله شمس الوعدي المستشار
مركز الشرق الاوسط للدراسات الاستراتيجيه
واشكر ضيفي من الكويت الدكتور عبد الله
الشايجي استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
الكويت تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه
جديده فيما وراء خبر جديد الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء